the quest for artificial intelligence
began more than 80 years ago the idea
was that computer technology would one
day be powerful enough to carry out
tasks better and more efficiently than
humans we've got to actually say hello
to today AI has come of age it's already
having an impact on many parts of human
life from self-driving cars to finding
soul mates but perhaps its greatest
impact will be on medicine and the way
we monitor human health dr. Eric Topol
is one of the most influential doctors
in digital medicine the pioneering
American cardiologist has helped develop
drugs that have saved countless lives
he's now at the forefront of the AI
revolution in health care
these are his prescriptions for
transforming the future of human health
the overarching goal is to bring that
humanity if we do this right we can
rescue the problems of healthcare
[Music]
the doctor-patient relationship is a
founding principle of health care and
medicine the first step is to eliminate
keyboards and computer screens and
clinical encounters some doctors in the
West can spend up to twice as many hours
on medical paperwork than with their
patients in the years ahead we should be
able to eliminate the data clerk
functions of clinicians these are
mutually hated as much by patients as by
doctors and clinicians AI tools such as
speech recognition technology but in our
common place in homes could be used in
clinical settings for capturing data and
notes allowing doctors to concentrate on
people we have a problem with accuracy
and efficiency
trained on a huge resource of medical
data the power of AI learning can read
some images more accurately than humans
whether it's a pattern like a scan or a
slide or prediction AI can really rev up
the accuracy and that is important for a
better diagnosis better treatments
better outcomes lower-cost powerful
machines can interpret scans 150 times
faster than radiologists and can work 24
hours a day
AI can even suggest a diagnosis many
conditions could be AI diagnosed and so
the time that a doctor comes into play
is very specific to important diagnosis
[Music]
data is critical for improving our
understanding of disease and illness the
more we understand the better the
chances of preventing diagnosing and
curing but currently only about 5% of
medical data is used effectively we had
a problem with generating so much data
terabytes of data for each person but we
didn't have a way to analyze we didn't
have a way to extract the juice the
distillate of this now we do and that's
what artificial intelligence is really
about harness to wireless devices AI
could oversee every facet of people's
health data from family history to food
intake to exercise people will have the
opportunity to have this real integrated
view of themselves to help prevent
illness to help guide them for better
management of conditions over time we'll
see this virtual coach for promoting
health constant ai monitoring could
transform the most prolific diseases
that demand the most care such as
diabetes this would empower people to
take charge of their own health
another way that AI will kick in over
time he said get rid of hospital rooms
we can monitor patients in the comfort
of their own home because they can have
the sensors that would provide the same
type of monitoring as if someone was in
the intensive care unit caring for
people outside of medical settings would
not only prevent hospital-acquired
disease it could also save money all
these things favor this shift of
reliance on a patient's bedroom rather
than the hospital room we're talking
about a whole lot of people that don't
need to be employed in the hospital
setting that is a great way to reduce
the burden in the future in the United
States hospital costs five thousand
dollars a night so you could get a lot
of data plans that go four years for
that cost
[Music]
if the clinical community stands up for
patients and say all the power
efficiency productivity workflow from AI
is going to be used to give the gift of
time to doctors and nurses and patients
that's where we flip this thing and
achieve a rescue mission for healthy
[Music]
you